[Musique]
cette semaine en quête des anciens
élèves de l'institut des sourds muets de
montréal raconte toute l'histoire
d'horreur que j'aurai vécu les
m'assoyais sur ses genoux sur sa cuisse
c'est arrivé aussi qui prime avant qu'il
m'a forcé à le masturber et engraissés
progrès que ça leur faisait du bien de
nous frapper comme si mon truc c'était
eux qui avaient le pouvoir et la
pratique ces temps ci doit être puni
j'ai pleuré je souhaitais tellement
revoir ma mère
[Musique]
et peut-on faire confiance ou peuvent
canadienne
de vieux débris de viande coller aux
convoyeurs et on pouvait voir que ça
date pas d'hier
ils n'ont pas mis en place les mesures
qui étaient nécessaires pour corriger la
situation
on doit avoir un meilleur système de
surveillance au canada
[Musique]
bienvenue en quête un nouveau chapitre
dans l'histoire d'horreur de la
pédophilie par des congrégations
religieuses
un recours collectif vient d'être
autorisée contre les clercs de saint
viateur
les victimes seraient des élèves sourds
certains de ces enfants parmi les plus
vulnérables auraient été réduits à
l'esclavagé sexuel ce que vous entendrez
dans ce reportage est très dur nous
tenons à vous en aviser enquêtes sur des
événements extrêmement graves qui
auraient été commis pendant des années à
l'école des sourds de montréal je
m'appelle yves je suis sourd muet je
viens à bitumer n'y a pas d'école pour
moi ici
[Musique]
à l'âge de 8 ans je dois partir au
montréal ma famille est pauvre
mon père doit vendre une de nos douze
vaches pour payer mes vêtements et le
trajet d'autobus
tu content je vais apprendre la langue
d'ici là voici arrivée à l'institut des
sourds de montréal je ne reverrai pas ma
famille pendant des mois
je parle ma première nuit au dortoir
épuisé par le trajet on matin mon voisin
feyssine bertoua lève-toi fatigué je me
rendors un frère arrive une fratrie à la
main avec un bâton je comprends pas ce
qui m'arrive
j'ai encore aucune idée de ce qu'ils
matin l'histoire divjak est celle de
bien d'autres qui se raconte aujourd'hui
pour la première fois à mon arrivée à
l'école c'est un 68
j'avais 8 ans je savais que j'allais à
ce moment alors rentré dans ma vraie
famille ma famille sociale
que j'allais dormir avec d'autres sur
d'autres enfants sauf qu'on allait
partager le même environnement qu'on
allait société j'en étais content parce
que je pouvais communiquer en langue des
signes
j'étais contente d'aller à l'institut
des sourds de montréal joue très mal à
l'école c'est la première fois que je me
mettais dans une école pour apprendre
des choses dix morts mais je prenne ce
avec l'aide d'interprètes c'est homme
sourd et muet dénonce
il aurait été battu et violé
systématiquement par des religieux dans
la seule école qu'elles pouvaient
fréquenter une histoire d'horreur qui se
seraient déroulés dans le québec moderne
des années 60 en 1921 les clercs de
saint viateur ouvre la première grande
école pour sourds à montréal des
générations d'enfants arrivent comme
pensionnaire de toutes les régions du
québec
cette congrégation et dans
l'enseignement depuis longtemps auprès
d'enfants en entendant des clercs de
saint viateur ont entre autres fondé le
collège bourget à rigaud et le séminaire
de joliette
mais ils se sont donnés comme mission
d'apprendre aux sourds à communiquer ils
marquent l'histoire de l'éducation en
créant l'institut des sourds de montréal
[Musique]
comme on le voit dans une vidéo amateur
les élèves de l'institut ressemble à
tous les enfants de cet âge
mais derrière ces jeux se cache une
grande blessure on se couche à 7h30 à se
fermer un des frères avec une lampe de
poche circuler et arrive devant moi me
demande de le suivre
me prend par la main moi le petit
bonhomme que j'étais à 8 ans je le suis
on arrive dans sa chambre ferme la porte
donc lui retire ses pantalons et
commence à m'embrasser un peu partout
quand il me montrait clairement son
pénis je l'avais devant moi devant mon
design je voulais quoi regarder il
touché avec son gland sur la joue
pendant ce temps l'oeil se masturber me
demander de de prendre son pénis dans ma
main et y signer éjaculer éjaculer sur
mon ventre
[Musique]
j'ai eu une news est indescriptible
et le prêter des fiches s'étant pas s'il
va être puni et je suis retourné dans le
dortoir me coucher j'ai pleuré je
voulais ma mère je souhaitais tellement
revoir ma mère ce moment là ce n'est que
récemment que denis chalifoux a raconté
à son frère marcel comment il serait
devenu selon ses propres termes un
esclave sexuelle il aurait été agressée
sexuellement par plusieurs frères
pendant des années il y avait des petits
vie et l'époque des têtes de lit en
métal et lui est libre le frein tir
entre les jambes pour que ça vienne pour
qu'il vienne avec lui d'autres se cacher
en dessous de villy à ce moment-là
demeurer loin de montréal compte dormant
nul quand ils repartaient c'est toujours
la crise où les jeunes est reparti mais
moi ce que l'on pensait tous parce
qu'ils s'ennuyaient c'est normal
le passage à la vie sa voix avait l'air
d'un petit gars costauds dans son
chandail de capitaine de l'équipe de
hockey et se souvient de son passage à
l'institut à la fin des années 50
nous lui présentons des photos d'anciens
professeurs fermé lesquels il reconnaît
ses agresseurs lui la berge
c'était pas de professeur
il était vraiment qu air dans la salle
de classe
c'est toujours l'après-midi à 14 ans ont
fermé les rideaux de la classe que moi
je restais pour les leçons c'est arrivé
aussi qui a pris ma main qui m'a forcé à
le masturber je voulais pas donc de
force il ya mis son pénis dans la bouche
puis m'a forcée à lui faire une
fellation
il ya déjà curieux dans ma bouche moi
j'ai eu un maire un rôle qu'a donc j'ai
vomi j'ai craché partage souhaitent un
seuil mais ils me forcèrent à ramasser
le vomi
j ride dirige le centre des sourds de
montréal voué à la défense des droits
des sourds
depuis quelques années il reçoit les
confidences dans ses élèves de
l'institut lui même n'a pas été abusée
sexuellement mais en tant qu'ancien
élève
il témoigne du climat de violence
parfois même dans l'escalier une poussée
dans les escaliers aux déboulés les
escales dean est encore là on ont doublé
les escaliers plomb être blessé puis par
la suite
encore une frappe et envoie des
escaliers soit je l'aï vu j'ai vu
c'était violent c'était 100 car audrey
qui avait agressé faudrait que ça leur
faisait du bien de nous frapper comme si
montres extra utérine pouvoir
le père tim cléments surnommé le père
bonbons aurait échangé des sucreries
contre des faveurs sexuelles
prémat soyez sûr celle sur ses genoux
sur sa cuisse tenait une donnée le
rebond maintenant
en m'appuyant sur le dos maintenant
enlève tes vêtements plus ça recommence
je pensais que c'était comme ça que ça
fonctionne et que ça fonctionnait quoi
que quand on était au pensionnat chez
les frères que tous les soirs il fallait
avoir un contact sexuel avec eux
[Musique]
le matin au réveil j'étais épuisé on
sera en classe moi je dormais sur mon
bureau
re savoie n'oubliera jamais le premier
abus le frère hervé neveu l'aurait
violée pour le punir d'avoir discuté
avec un ami
le fal qui une fois menée dans sa
chambre comme punition puis voir son
pantalon
[Musique]
puis il a pris ma main pour que je l'a
masturbé là moi je voulais pas donc le
limon il m'a pris par les cheveux m'a
fait mettre à genoux rob savoie aurait
été violé plusieurs fois au point d'en
avoir l'anus déchiré c'est au collège
aller à l'effet chalet ou en effet une
petite centaine de fois puis à l'hôpital
4,5 fois peut-être
alors ils ont vu ils ont vu l eau claire
une semaine à l'hôpital
j'avais des détours jauzion celui tout
ça parce que j'étais très faibles donc
une semaine deux semaines pour me
redonner de la force de change était
rétabli je retourner au collège puis les
abus recommencer voulons temps après
toutefois la bvk violence aucun médecin
ne sonne l'alarmé
encore moins les firmes et de l'école
alors vous aviez vous faire soigner à
l'infirmerie
et là aussi on aime vous êtes vous ça
vous dit
exactement
le soigner il m'appelle m call même
donner des bonbons puis il en profite
elle pourrait y avoir des séances de
masturbation pas puis c'était quelque
chose d'habituel puis de répétitif le
pendant toutes ces années là au dortoir
en classe à l'infirmerie
les élèves ne se sentait à l'abri nulle
part pas même dans les lieux sacrés il y
avait quatre cinq prêtres qui était dans
le confessionnal il y avait une lumière
rouge qui est indiqué ci est occupé où
les mets du devant le confessionnal à un
paiement y avait personne qui est en
ligne
ni on était tous en ligne devant les
auprès de paiement le prêt d'hp et mahut
ouvrait la porte
pourquoi quelle personne de vent mollit
demande aux gens de venir en ligne pour
que les gens n'y allait pas s'il savait
qu'il faisait les attouchements dans
courrier l'époque
[Musique]
après la pause les agresseurs sexuels ce
serait partagée des enfants
investissez sur 7 abuzar principaux que
je devais suivre en alternance
ceux qui travaillent et aux ménages ce
qui était à la cuisine les autres frères
qui enseignait
[Musique]
en 1968 le père jean marc pépin enseigne
à une scène de garçons sourds tonique et
anneaux campe ici et pierre des veillées
étaient dans sa classe nous les avons
retrouvés et se souviennent très bien de
leur professeur
c'est un bon professeur oui c'est un
très bon professeur mais très
autoritaire quand on faisait des erreurs
il voyait tout ils nous frappaient sur
la main ces élèves font tout le primaire
avec le père jean marc pépin il leur
enseigne le français les mathématiques
et la religion c'est lui qui les
préparent et leur donne la première
communion durant les vacances d'été les
deux mots qu'on avait de congé je te
lécher pierre et on a discuté on parle
et c'est que ma mère elle a vu nous on
jasait puis le vu quan par des pins
c'est quoi ce cinglé pascale six revues
singles qu'est ce que vous dites non non
il rien on parle de rien du tout et rien
le maïs contenant mon nom
elle décode les confidences des deux
garçons qui parle d'homosexualité
le père pépin leur aurait fait des
attouchements par la suite normandie on
est au niveau de la police clooney à la
maison mais dichato pas dire pas de
danger c'est pour ta sexualité donc la
police est venue on a raconté l'histoire
et ils vont faire pour être en pleine
des positions les policiers interrogent
tous les élèves de la classe du pertes
et pète les accusations criminelles
seront portées à la cour ils ont demandé
quelle était la nature des gestes
je leur explique à la coke je descendais
mes pantalons comme touché que je
touchais on me demande et du touch et
touch et jouit pourquoi il faisait ce je
sais pas il m'expliquait qu'est ce tu es
pour expliquer comment ça fonctionne et
le corps c'est pour l'avenir et l
instruction c'est important j'avais pas
ça mais je le faisais parce que j'avais
pas nous avons retrouvé le dossier
judiciaire de la cour de bien-être
social où s'est tenu le procès le père
jean marc pépin a été accusé de voies de
fait et des citations à la délinquance
contre cinq élèves
est-ce qu'il a été trouvé coupable nous
on lundi nous ont dit que papin il
aurait pu à l'école nous n'avons pas pu
retracer le jugement
mais qu'est-il advenu du père pépin à la
suite du procès nous avons trouvé la
réponse dans un hommage que lui ont
rendu récemment les clercs de saint
viateur il louange son passage à
l'institut des sourds six années de
présence auprès des démunis de louis six
années de joie de patience et de
recommencement
c'est l'éducateur en pleine possession
de ses moyens
une telle initiation le préparer
bellemans pour le collège bourget où il
fit le plus beau métier du monde
[Musique]
après l'institut des sourds le père
pépinvast enseigné au collège bourget de
rigaud jusqu'en 1988 pour ensuite
devenir curé et berti
nous l'avons joint cet été dans un
centre pour religieux à sherbrooke au
téléphone et soutient avoir été acquitté
en 1973 il refuse de commenter des
allégations d'aujourd'hui un de ses
anciens élèves est allé le rencontrer
muni d'une caméra cachée la voie que
vous entendrez et celle de l'interprète
qui l'accompagnent je me rappelle
comment et des jeux a touché sexuelle
mais même à l'intérieur de mon pantalon
un allemand italien à l'intérieur je
suis souvenirs l'eau je me rappelle bien
en dessous enfin bon comme ça
faites-vous partie gorik lorsque vous
faites des fautes pour vous c'est
correct au nom d'allah est volontaire
le père jean marc pépin ni et après et
s'excuse pour vous c'est sûr c'est
qu'avec
je m'excuse comme excuse
je m'excuse
c'est beau pierre noreau est un ancien
clercs de saint viateur un ex collègue
de jean marc pépin il n'a été témoin
d'aucun abus mais ils le trouvaient trop
affectueux avec les enfants
souvent il y avait un élève assis sur
ses genoux puis qu'at elle tenait de
servir mon pays
pissevin technique qui aimait beaucoup
beaucoup celle des filles elles sont que
trois poteaux pour pour un enseignant
avec des élèves plusieurs frères
auraient été agressées systématiquement
plusieurs enfants à répétition pendant
des années dans mon sommeil je voyais
juste à main il en arrivait je voyais
deux petits garçons s'éloigner d'isère
six jours qu'ils pensent mais cette fois
il y avait une rotation ça changeait de
ça change et de ressort vous avez
pendant dix ans alès des sourds et muets
combien combien de personnes ont abusé
vous pendant ces années là
[Musique]
investissez sur cet amuseur principaux
que je devais suivre en alternance ce
qui qui travaillait aux ménages ce qui
était à la cuisine les autres frères qui
enseignait les autres frères qui étaient
responsables des salles d'animation les
autres frères de ci et de ça et de ci et
de ça
un recours collectif vient d'être
autorisée contre les clercs de saint
viateur
il lui aurait 36 agresseur sur 40 ans
prête frère et employés laïque 64
anciens élèves d avoir été agressée
comment vous réagissez s ils sont que
sur prêts je m'attendais pas à ça c'est
vraiment pour moi une chose son secret
beaucoup de monde qui a eu un seul de
ces brimades surprend mais ce que vous
les croyez les ans ses élèves
oui ben j'y croirai mes positions ultra
4 seul onglet ce que c'est exagéré ce
jeudi
serge la roche est lui aussi un ancien
professeur mais beaucoup de ceux qui
venaient me voir avec parce qu'il
faisait confiance
j'étais une bonne personne et où je
crois oui mais de vous voir et vous
disais quoi il m'avait averti mes
parents averti la police
mais qu'est ce que vous avez fait mais
pour répondre je suis garde des sceaux
pour moi
j'avais pas comment agir est en cause
que j'ai en étant professeur
mais aujourd'hui je suis capable d'aimer
team serge laroche n'a pas trouvé le
courage de dénoncer c'est peut-être
parce qu'il est aussi un ancien élève de
l'institut
oui je crois les étudiants et à mesure
oui moi même je les vis tu mouilles
comme moi vous avez été abusés où ils
ont été visés par deux frères oui oui
par bus 1 c'était un surveillant de
dortoir et c'était également le
professeur de classe et à l'infirmerie
c'est un autre frère oui en a il y en a
4 5 est encore vivant mais il y en a
plusieurs que des abuseurs qui ont cédé
des acteurs laissent le temps ils se
sont mariés au et des familles puis
comme si rien n'était personne ce film a
été tourné par l'éclair en 1963 pour
faire la promotion de l'institut
on y voit entre autres le frère jean
jacques archambault
aujourd'hui marié
cette personne elle est d'avoir été
abusés par cet homme dont françois
peltier qui nous écrit j'avais 14 ans
environ et je me suis lié d'amitié avec
un autre frère jean jacques archambault
lui avait un atelier vie je l'aide à des
fois
puis un jour et m'a fait boire du for
dj's et j'étais sous un peu il m'a
violée
d'autres ma vie ça pas été facile pour
moi
j'ai toujours ça dans ma tête je herman
cain dernier les frères jean jacques
archambault
comment il était avec vous la même chose
avec archambault avec lui même chose
avec lui ou ses pantalons puis nous
forcer à le masturber au téléphone jean
jacques archambault s'est dit totalement
surpris des allégations contre lui
il n'a pas voulu nous donner d'entrevue
je vous les voyez dans les autobus ils
s'expriment par gestes mais entre eux
mais à l'école ici on s'efforce
notamment de leur enseigner la parole et
la lecture je le lève le frère viateur
gervais qu'on voit ici dans une émission
de radio canada a été directeur des
études pendant presque quarante ans à
l'institut même lui aurait fait des
victimes
c'est la faiblesse que ces jeunes filles
une soif de 9 de violence une soif de
sexe oui oui
ses frères l'or était pour marier pour
personne dans leur vie avait pris des
poses l'appétit sexuel était quand même
là et au lieu d'avoir une épouse ils
nous prenaient nous il y avait le
spectacle était plus large parce qu'il y
en a qui a tant que religieux ils
suivaient pas au règlement du jeu comme
il en avait le mais la méditation tôt
matin la messe bondés des choses le jeu
puis on a négligé son coma on a
peut-être qu'il y avait qu il y avait à
l'esprit un peu plus large jusqu'à abusé
d'un enfant
ouais peut-être moins pour le jour du
tap tempo grave
oui cet ampli qui pourrait pas parler
oui
la pause bbc
je crois pas que je suis un résidu et je
veux leur prouver je voulais poursuivre
et qu'ils me paient tous les dommages
qu'ils ont causés
[Musique]
m
l'immeuble qui abrite l institut des
sourds de montréal fera place bientôt
a320 condominiums évalué à 15 millions
de dollars
l'immeuble a été vendu récemment selon
l'acte de vente pour la somme de 1 $
le promoteur nous explique qu'il a une
entente secrète avec l'éclair pour taire
le montant réel de la transaction des
clercs ne voudrais pas que nous sachions
combien cette vente leur a rapporté au
moment où un recours collectif pèsent
contre eux pour l'instant 64 ans et
élèves réclament 100 mille dollars
chacun en dédommagement le recours
pourrait atteindre 6 millions 500 mille
dollars selon plusieurs
ce qui s'est passé entre ses murs a eu
de graves conséquences sur leur vie
je connaissais pas le mou donc je peux
pas exprimer ce que je vivais je veux
pas parler du mot sexe parce que je
connaissais même pas je dois simplement
j'aime pas l'école je veux pas retourner
à l'école mais ce qui aurait pu en
parler à bout avoue par pensez vous moi
je pense que non
je pense qu'il avait hier pour t'ouvrir
aso je pense que leur époque que vers 11
ans denis aurait vendu ses services
sexuels à des frères et à des employés
laïque à l'intérieur des murs de l'école
ah ben oui de dollars de pièces mais par
un terreau riche
sachant que j'avais un peu d'argent
je ne sers à
peut-être que ça pourrait être une
source de revenus denis quitte l'école à
14 ans il ne sait ni lire ni écrire
nous
je pense que le principal enseignement
j'ai reçu deux c'était la sexualité
surtout cette limitation
ensuite quand je suis sorti dans dans le
monde
là je me suis dit qu'est ce que je dois
faire
puis la réponse me spontanément la
prostitution
j'étais dans le monde dans le monde dans
le monde de la drogue dans le monde de
l'alcool aller jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans
venez chez nous ou chez un autre pour
emprunter de l'argent
la bouche de la roue de la misère la
dépendance la dépendance
ces logis fait une tante j'ai voulu me
suicider et pour ça j'ai pris des
médicaments des pilules
après des années d'errance et d'autres
tentatives de suicide
denis a retrouvé un certain équilibre
mais il est toujours hanté par son passé
quand je vois des garçons le jeune
garçon dans la rue
[Musique]
pour moi ça nécessiterait pas beaucoup
d'efforts d'un accosté en avoir eu mon
épouse c'est certain que je serai au
buzzer d'enfants comme je l'étais à
musique dans mon enfance parce que c'est
en créant moins bien sûr s'étaient
dissipées j'ai essayé d'avoir une femme
j'aurais aimé savoir des enfants sûr
mais ça jamais été possible j'ai
toujours eu dans l'esprit dans les
mauvais les mauvais souvenirs de ce que
j'ai vécu au clair saint viateur dans le
plusieurs qui sont pas capables de
s'exprimer et on enregistrait s'ils
deviennent nerveux et il vient dans
l'ampleur des blocages avec tous les
années de caen sa sincère depuis tout
petit garçon y ont pas été capables de
s'exprimer
c'est comme de dire de briser la glace
ce n'est qu'à 50 ans et parce que
d'autres le font avec lui que denis
chalifoux trouve le courage de dénoncer
je vois certains des frères qui sont sur
facebook
ils ont une belle résidence ils vivent
confortablement
et moi dans tout ça 1 - je suis un
résidu 1
je suis un résidu qu'on a mis de côté je
crois pas que je suis un résidu et je
veux leur prouver
je veux les poursuivre et qu'ils me
paient tous les dommages qu'ils ont
causés
les clercs de saint viateur ont refusé
de nous accorder une entrevue dans le
cadre du recours collectif
ils ont voulu empêcher la publication
des noms des religieux viser la juge
leur a répondu il ne faut pas oublier
que l'autorisation du recours collectif
sert à décourager ou prévenir des abus
semblables et la divulgation des noms
fait partie de ce même but de
découragement et de prévention j'ai
toujours ces images lors ces images là
ma compagne constamment je regarde une
photo je vois pas un groupe d'enfants
saut je vois des enfants qui ont été
abusés sexuellement je vois la sexualité
ah oui oui sur cette photo la wii s'est
passé tel événement oui à cet endroit là
oui on m'a touché de telle façon
ah oui à tel endroit c'était autre chose
pour moi c'est ça fait remonter à la
surface
plein d'autres choses que les gens vont
procéder photons
[Musique]
les anciens élèves qui auraient été
victimes de sévices physiques uniquement
sont exclus du recours collectif et
considère qu'il s'agit là d'une grande
injustice puisqu'ils prétendent avoir eu
eux aussi des séquelles de ses années
passées à l'institut des sourds de
montréal après la pause l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments
après excellent food et pontel aux
attentes
il ya eu un nouveau système de
vérification de la conformité
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas eu encore
une très forte proportion d'inspecteurs
qui ont été formés à ce système là
[Musique]
devant l'ampleur du récent rappel de
viande contaminée au pays qu une de nos
équipes s'est penché sur des événements
pour découvrir que quatre ans après
l'épisode mortelle de listériose
chimiques olive
c'est un peu l'histoire qui se répète
peut-on faire confiance aux boeufs
canadienne c'est la question que
plusieurs chevaux au terme d'un examen
approfondi autorités canadiennes ont
sévèrement blâmé la compagnie x cube en
alberta mais notre système d'inspection
des aliments
at il été à hauteur de 1000 employés
travaillent habituellement dans cet
abattoir le deuxième plus grand au pays
le 27 septembre le gouvernement a retiré
son permis l usine de excel funds il y
avait des failles dans ces protocoles de
salubrité surveiller pourtant parsys
vétérinaire et 40 un spectale beaucoup
pour surveiller derrière ce rappel sans
précédant apparaissent maintenant des
indices qui annonçait la crise
mais qui ont échappé à la vigilance de
tous
[Musique]
ça fait dix jours que excellent food est
visé par un rappel quand le gouvernement
se rend compte de la gravité dès
maintenant dans les usines et qu'il
suspend sa production
c'est déjà trop tard pour dominer galère
ce jour là l'homme de 34 ans de
mcmasterville en montérégie ressent les
premiers symptômes d'une intoxication
alimentaire de l'écran pour vendre tu as
l'impression l'occupent très bien joué
avec un couteau dans l'intestin
notamment durant sa longue
hospitalisation 16 jours au total
son état se détériore gravement il y
avait paré pour mon collant un membre ou
colombes parce qu'il y avait trop de
duels ça demain donc avait pas de devoir
l'enlever ils ont eu peur pour mes reins
et on lui parle pour mon coeur abandonné
parce que c'était une douleur assez
importante a toléré pour mon corps quand
j'étais couché dans son lit puis que je
me demandais où est ce que j'allais
trouver la force pour endurer la
prochaine crainte qu'ils étaient dix sur
dix d'intensité je trouvais ça c'est
elle qui à 34 ans ça soit pénible comme
cibles
dominique a l'air est un des dix huit
cas d'infection à la bactérie e coli a
été formellement associés par la santé
publique à la viande produite dans
l'usiné de excellent foods
c'est peu si on considère qu'il ya plus
de 400 cas chaque année au pays
lusine en cause appartient à deux hommes
d'affaires discret les frères lit et
brian nelson
ils n'ont émis que de brefs communiqués
pas toujours claires sur un répondeur le
coup de maître topical marc lévesque et
les copies ont été pris et pendant les
mêmes dates de production carnac preda
rappel de beurre ainsi qu'une
déclaration dans laquelle il dit avoir
cru que excellent food et est un leader
dans l'industrie de la transformation du
boeuf en matière de sécurité alimentaire
les problèmes étaient manifestes dans
l'usiné affirme cet ancien fournisseur
lui même spécialisés en nettoyage et
désinfection de vieux débris de viande
coller aux convoyeurs et on pouvait voir
que ça date pas d'hier
[Musique]
même le syndicat reconnaît l'existence
de lacunes mais les travailleurs nous
aide pas dénoncer la situation des
travailleurs qui gagnent 7 dollars de
l'heure et qui craint de perdre son
emploi de dénoncer une situation que
même les inspecteurs du gouvernement
laisse passer
ce sont d'ailleurs des inspecteurs
américains qui détecte les premiers un
échantillon positif à la frontière en
septembre le rappel au canada ne
survient que deux semaines plus tard il
vise seulement la viande hachée les
autres pièces de viande continuent
d'être distribué dans le filet mignon 40
dominique a l'air malade et j'aime
beaucoup et zara comprendre pourquoi en
2012 le ca s'est pas faite du tac au tac
on trouvait ça ben ok ça revient d'une
campagne canadienne pourquoi n'y a pas
eu immédiatement une réaction du
gouvernement
ce petit abattoir lui aussi accrédité
par le fédéral nous a discrètement
ouvert ses portes
[Musique]
si on abat 405 un bail par semaine
l'équivalent de ce que excellent fund
traite en une solaire
la bactérie coupable peut se trouver à
plusieurs étapes de la chaîne de
production
dès l'entrée des bêtes dans l' usine
pendant les corsages jusqu au lavage des
carcasses la clé ce sont les tests de
dépistage et c'est là que se trouve une
des grandes failles de excellent foule
et n'ont pas fait les analyses des
trends des indices d'une façon assez
rigoureuse et qui des fois ils n'ont pas
pris ils n'ont pas mis en place les
mesures qui étaient nécessaires pour
corriger la situation
ça rappelle de mauvais souvenirs le même
problème s'était produit chez mes
qualifs en 2008
depuis les usines doivent signaler les
tests qui s'avère positif et que celle
ci ne l'a pas fait la compagnie a
peut-être pas fait le suivi approprié
mais peut-être aussi que les âges les
inspecteurs qui étaient sur le site ont
pas eu la vigilance nécessaire par
exemple nous avons découvert c'est tout
et elle dépend d'en réaliser quatre mois
avant la crise
il révèle justement des lacunes dans
l'échantillonnage et aurait pu alerter
les inspecteurs manque de vigilance mais
aussi de formation le rôle des
inspecteurs a beaucoup changé ces
dernières années
2 un nouveau système de vérification de
la conformité qui était mis en place
pour accroître série les suivis ou
surtout au niveau de l'échantillonnage
microbiologiques et s'assurer que le
suivi va être fait de façon plus
rigoureuse
effectivement il ya pas eu encore une
très forte proportion des inspecteurs
qui ont été formés à ce système la
vérification faite la majorité des
inspecteurs posté dans l' usine de excel
funds n'ont pas reçu la formation
requise pour ce programme
bien qu'il soit en vigueur depuis quatre
ans le gouvernement américain sont
inquiétés lors de sa dernière inspection
des usines canadiennes en 2009
il qualifiait le travail inégal de
supervision de faiblesse du système
d'inspection
il y avait un laisser aller total tout
changement se heurter à la réticence de
la direction de excellent food affirme
cet ancien fournisseur
il dit avoir soumis des recommandations
à la compagnie pour améliorer les
pratiques dans l'usiné mais sans succès
j'ai senti qu'on accordait aucune
importance à ces recommandations
qu'elles n'étaient pas les bienvenus et
qu'on leur portait pas attention on dope
pose certainement pas se fier uniquement
à ce qui est fait par la coupe par les
compagnies la plupart sont responsables
mais il y en a qui lui tiennent qui ne
sont pas donc la leçon à retenir de cet
épisode là on doit avoir un meilleur
système de surveillance au canada mais
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments restent incapables d'expliquer
comment les nombreuses déficiences mis
au jour pendant son enquête ont pu
échapper à ses inspecteurs
et elle ne compte pas imposer de
sanction à l'usiné c du jamais vu pour
chute pour les conséquences pour nous
nous avons une grande séquence assez
sérieux lesigne
les usines fermées
autre lourde de conséquences pour excel
food la destruction de 450 tonnes de
viande on était capable au canada
d'assurer la traçabilité de la viande
une fois qu'elle entre dans le réseau
complexe des distributeurs on a jeté par
précaution surtout pour rassurer les
consommateurs
c'est devenu une crise d'une ampleur
extraordinaire quand le politique se
mêler de ça quand on a mis en doute l
la réaction d' agences par rapport à
l'épisode initial puis l'osce a donné
une question de gestion de la confiance
du consommateur beaucoup plus que les
questions de gérer un épisode de
toxi-infections alimentaires
le dominical air lui n'est pas pressé de
remanger du boeuf
d'autant plus que sa conjointe mélissa a
elle aussi été contaminés quoique moins
gravement les séquelles se font encore
sentir
je suis capable de marcher je te dirai
je suis capable de vaquer à quelques
activités ménagères
juste avant de prendre 11 millions
d'intoxication alimentaire surviennent
chaque année au canada
maintenant qu'il en connaît le prix de
munich a l'air reste sur ses gardes
j'ai confiance qui font le job correct
mais aussi j'ai vu pis j'ai moi-même eu
l'expérience qui peuvent avoir des ratés
puis laissez passer des produits qui
sont des femmes lusine 2xl food a repris
ses activités il y à un mois
on y a déjà relevé de nouveaux
manquements lagence d'inspection des
aliments assure qu'elle va maintenir une
surveillance accrue
le temps qu'il faudra
[Musique]
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments n'a répondu à aucune de nos
demandes d'entrevue pour ce reportage
si vous voulez nous contacter consultez
notre site internet à l'adresse suivante
enquête et rediffusée le samedi à 13h la
première chaîne de radio-canada et le
dimanche à 18 heures jeux réseaux
d'information
[Applaudissements]
la semaine prochaine enquête
une chasse à l'homme sur internet la
ferme à newton
[Musique]
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir prochaine